the man you all have been waiting for
Michael J
NS thank you very much you're all too
kind don't belonger you genocidal Mania
oh there we go finally I was wondering
where you were when a conservative
speaks on a college campus one of two
things usually happens activists and
indoctrinated students try to burn the
place down or leftist groups post
strategies for limiting or shutting down
the event and then hide in their dorms
and then just hope that no one shows up
both responses are to be expected from
miseducated students who scroll through
the endless hit pieces from leftwing
outlets and then have those lies
reinforced by their liberal professors
do you think there's a chance that they
sat down and listen to him speak that
their minds would be
changed yeah some of them there is a
third option which I greatly prefer that
is when my producer Journeys into the
mob of protesters and finds someone
willing to cross the picket line away
from the activists and the Mindless
chance to talk with me directly you
fascist I look like one do I yeah we ask
you a few questions no I do mind thank
you often no matter how welcoming the
invitation for a cozy front row seat at
the speech and a friendly discussion
with me afterward the offer falls on
deaf
ears why also invested in hating other
people and telling other people what to
do with their bodies does anyone want to
talk to Michael NOS after the speech to
do with you and it's of your business
anybody other times my producer left out
in the
cold but sometimes you find someone like
Wes at Clemson University who chose not
just to hold some nonsensical sign while
screaming at people waiting to hear me
speak but rather to come listen to what
I had to say then to ask a question to
challenge My Views a respectful strategy
that gave W and me the opportunity to
sit down and talk face to face thanks
for sitting down no problem so your name
is Wes yes Wes and you did not protest
me I did not but you disagreed with me I
do disagree with you in many issues
including what you talked about today so
tonight we talked about IVF and
surrogacy you got up and you asked a
question I thought it was really good so
you disagree with me on this topic you
came in disagreeing with me did I change
your mind at all through the the
speech I didn't disagree with the
reasoning I do disagree with you know
the principle I don't disagree with IVF
and um surrogacy but I understand why
you do and I don't think you're wrong
for believing what you believe so if if
you agree with my reasoning and you
think that I made a at least a logically
sound
argument then don't you have to come
over to my opinion well I it kind of
goes back to my opinions on everything
like I am personally uh pro-choice but I
believe believe that people who are
pro-life I don't think that they are
stupid and wrong I think that they have
logic in their reasoning but I also
think that people who believe the
opposite also have logic in their
reasoning and I almost believe it is
just a just a moral difference that is
almost can't be broken I think it's just
a difference of morals so I agree with
you that people who disagree are usually
not evil and they're usually not even
stupid usually usually but if two people
have opposite views on a question that
that has an objective answer to it then
at most one of those people is right
right contrary things can't
simultaneously be correct right M so if
you say in this wonderfully polite and
uh you know respectful way that you say
look I'm pro choice I support legal
abortion but I think that the pro-lifers
make really good arguments and their
logic is consistent MH for me at least
if someone makes a really good argument
and it's logically consistent and I
can't find a flaw in their
argument I I have to come over to their
side of the argument I think that
sometimes that there's just a moral
disagreement not necessarily that
someone's completely right or completely
wrong me personally I believe that what
gives people value is not just a beating
heart or the fact that you are a human I
believe that is your your Consciousness
in your personhood that's my personal
moral belief but I don't think someone
else is wrong for believing that they
don't think that's what gives someone
value they believe it's a beating heart
and brain function and a
body their very existence yes exactly
that I believe that people I don't think
that that's I disagree with it but I
don't think that that is illogical or I
guess I disagree with it but I don't
think it's an incorrect way of thinking
you you don't you don't see the flaw and
the logic you just you're still
confident that the person that that they
have the wrong side of the argument or
at the very least that you have the
right side of the
argument I I guess I guess I would say
that I well because it's my belief I
would of course think that I'm correct
and that they are incorrect but it's not
not as simple for me as oh you're an
idiot you're wrong that's a stupid way
of thinking have you ever changed your
mind on one of these questions I used to
be I grew up with a conservative family
my brother's conservative I was very
conservative growing up and I actually
switched to becoming a liberal happened
I got indoctrinated by the
college that's the best and most precise
answer yeah is that what did it really
happen at College not I I was about a a
senior in high school in the transition
started happening I used to consider
myself uh fiscally conservative but
socially liberal that's what all teenage
boys say so that the girl still like us
but we exactly and that's kind of you
know that's the start of the liberal
pipeline it is that is the begin you're
you're very uh perceptive of these
things I wonder if you're a little too
respectful
meaning if you really believe say that
the thing that gives a person value the
reason not to kill a person like through
abortion is not their existence it's not
a beating heart it's not it's
Consciousness and you said that's the
determining Factor then I would respond
to that and I would say okay well it
would it be okay to kill an unconscious
person someone who's asleep or who's in
a coma but who might likely come out of
the coma that would be an example of
someone who's not conscious but who
still has a right to life it is of my
understanding that we do take we do take
people off of life support that are in
comas some times Well if they have like
brain death or something but I'm just
saying a coma they were in a car
accident there let's say they're in a
medically induced coma or something and
there's a some great likelihood that
they're going to come out of the coma
I've heard someone put it this way it is
the ability of the person to project
Consciousness in the sense that their
body has that function it is capable of
projecting a conscious experience so so
even if the person is not at the time
actually conscious there is the
potential for Consciousness there but
then you would apply that same
description to a baby in the womb that
baby might not be actively conscious
there but they certainly have the
potential for Consciousness I wouldn't
say that it has the potential or the
ability to project Consciousness in that
moment physically it's
incapable guy the same with the guy in
the coma his body is developed to the
point where it would be able to project
a a conscious experience but it's
incapacitated yes and I and I think that
that also play plays a role into it the
fact that you were a conscious being and
you've been experiencing Life as a
conscious human and then some
unfortunate accident or whatever may
have happened put you into an
unconscious State I think that the fact
that there was a conscious experience
beforehand does play some role in the
value of the person so having been
conscious so you you notice you've now
sort of changed the Criterion because
you're saying well it's no longer being
ious but it's having been conscious at
some point which would separate someone
who is asleep or in a coma from a baby
in the womb who has never been conscious
but has the potential to be conscious
later then one might bring up the case
of um killing the elderly do you support
euthanasia assisted suicide you know
whatever euphemism they want to call
I've I've struggled with that I'm not I
don't have firm convictions either way
whenever people bring up like medically
assisted suicide I have not formed an
opinion on that yet I'm not in support
or against it I would have to you know
learn more about it and really about my
morals according to the setup that
you've just made you're saying if you've
ever been conscious and you've sort of
fallen out of the active use of your
conscious faculties that it would be
wrong to kill that person so that would
be an argument against youth in Asia for
the scile or demented in that case
though I don't sorry to interrupt I I
don't think it's like steadfast if
you've been conscious before you
absolutely have value that cannot be
taken away I think it's on a like a
caseby case basis but then what is the
what is the principle by which you you
discern one case from
another I don't personally I would have
it would just have to be on a case-by
casee basis I don't have this you know
this rule that I go by of but then this
is what's so curious about this because
you're saying I don't have a rule I'm
not applying reason exactly to to this
question I'm just kind kind of going on
my gut and that's what a lot of people
do what's strange about that though for
for you is that you show up to a lecture
given by someone who you go in
disagreeing with but then you come to at
the end of it you say well you know you
have your logic I have my logic who we
can't really reason about these things
in an objective way I think well then
why show up if you're not going to come
to a conclusion if you're not going to
say no you're wrong or I was wrong and
now I agree with you or actually I still
disagree with you because here's the fla
in your argument if you're not going to
grant that there's some objective
reality to these arguments that might
pertain to a great many people or
everybody and what's the point of the
logic well there's I you know I don't
come here to get my mind changed or
change anybody else's mind I think that
hearing other opinions whether you
personally believe that they're going to
change yours or not it it's just healthy
in general and I support free speech and
and also to be frank I'm here because
I'm friends with a lot of yaf people and
they asked me to come and I was like
sure sure I'll come you're like the
you're like the most amiable liberal on
campus and he say sure I'll come it's
just I Wes you're a you're a confounding
figure because you might be the nicest
guy I've ever met in a college campus
you might be the most open-minded guy
and yet I feel defeated because you're
saying Michael your arguments all
arguments they don't work on me I I
believe that abortion is just a it's a
moral disagreement I think that some
people have one moral code of ethics and
some people have a opposing moral
Viewpoint if I say 2 plus 2 equals 4 mhm
that's a view that we would both agree
to and that's my opinion someone might
say I've heard people say this that when
you really think about 2 plus 2 equal 5
mhm you don't agree with that and I
don't agree definitely not now those are
those are contradictory opinions 2 plus
two cannot simultaneously be four and
five at the same time it can't happen MH
so one of them is right and one of them
is wrong yes and you can't dispute that
a fetus is a is a human it is a human I
don't disagree with that where the
morals come into play there's
no
I don't personally believe that there is
any set of facts that tells you what
gives human value I think that's what
the argument is about where morality
what gives a human value and I don't
think that that is something that can
be science I guess it objectively known
objectively known exactly you can you
know can you know that it's better it's
morally better to help a little old lady
cross the street than it is to kick a
little baby in the head can you know
that for a fact you see I personally
don't agree in objective morality you
don't know you don't if someone came to
you this is just you there's no cameras
well there are cameras but imagine there
were no cameras and someone came to you
and said hey Wes just between you and me
man there's a guy who's helping a little
old lady across the street and there's a
guy who's kicking a little baby in the
head just cuz he's a sadist mhm is one
of those guys morally better than the
other guy obviously I believe so because
I have a moral code of ethics and
I believe those to be true so of course
I would say that where do you get your
morality
from uh
Evolution uh maybe a Evolution never
gave me any morality well maybe a higher
being I'm not not a Christian I may not
be a
Christian I'm I'm told by Christians
that I'm not a Christian but I I do
think that there can be a higher power
that created the world it's like the
non-contradiction thing again you're
you're not a Christian but you're not
not a Christian well I've been pushed
pushed out of the Christian by whom who
pushed you out talk to him well I mean
some people could say I led myself out
because I have moral disagreements with
certain things in the Bible and I've
always rationalized my whole what's that
shellfish yeah you say I love shellfish
I like shellfish too there's lots of
moral exactly lots of moral
disagreements that I have with the Bible
and I've been saying okay I believe in
God but the God that I believe in and
want to believe in doesn't necessarily
think those things that are in the Bible
if you get your morality From Evolution
well I don't know necessarily if that's
where it comes from it's just but
because EV
evolution in theory just exists to
propagate the species right it's just
it's just the process by which a species
adapts to its environment to propagate
itself that's all it is so Evolution
doesn't care at all about good or bad it
just cares about life or death it seems
like you're looking for love in all the
wrong places you know if you're if
you're looking for for good or bad
you're you're not going to find it in
any theory of evolution Evolution could
have guided you in such a way to believe
all sorts of things as long as it would
impel behavior that were conducive to to
uh reproducing so don't you have to look
somewhere else for good or bad well I'm
not necessar I I completely understand
what you're saying and I'm not claiming
that my morals do Come From Evolution I
don't really know where my morals come
from I was raised the way I was raised
and I just have the belief system that I
believe but even people in Tahiti you
know or wherever in papoa new guine even
though they believe all you know they
believe some weird stuff and they do
some weird stuff but there are certain
things that everyone every people for
all of human history just kind of know
even if they express it differently you
know we we know that murder is wrong we
know that theft is wrong people
transgress those but they every culture
knows this right and it can't just be
the particular environment in which you
were raised there has to be something
perhaps more objective and Universal
about it well going back to Evolution I
don't think that again I don't think
that all morals Come From Evolution but
I think specifically knowing that murder
is wrong probably does Come From
Evolution wanting to you know make sure
the the race continues it's if you
murder people that's bad for the human
race would you murder anyone right now
no no you wouldn't but the thing is the
moment that you become aware of the The
evolutionary impulses in you that have
tricked you into believing that murder
is objectively wrong when it's not
that's just a trick we've we've
concocted in order to propagate the
species well the moment you become aware
of that then you can contradict the
moral order right because it's not
objectively true it's just a product of
evolution it's just something to to to
spread the species so if
you if you are aware of that now and
it's not objectively binding and you
could benefit you know some guy's got a
million dollars in a satchel and you
could kill them and no one would find
out you take the money and you could you
could live a great life something tells
me you still wouldn't do that well I
wouldn't but I personally don't think
that um just the fact that I know where
they come from I don't think would give
me the ability to go against them I
think that there's still that deep gut
feeling that's ingrained in me that
tells me that murder is wrong if I know
that that came from Evolution that
doesn't change the fact that I have a
gut feeling that tells me that murder is
wrong even if you've arrived at that
from your reason what you're saying is
no my gut instinct is is going to
overpower my
reason which is what you've been telling
me the whole time well I don't think
that I don't even necessarily believe
that I did get my morals From Evolution
I there very well could be a a higher
power and a Creator I do not dispute
that
but I don't think that I can just say
that murder is wrong I think that that
you can't force that view on someone
else you can't say that it's objectively
true is what you're saying I I I I think
that morals and what we decide as a as a
world or I guess a country or Society is
wrong is based on the collective
subjective morality of all the different
people put together I think that if if
everyone in America in their subjective
moral viewpoints thought that murder was
okay then murder would be legal well it
would be legal but but you still
wouldn't think it's okay I wouldn't but
I mean that's my subjective morality I
don't think that some I your objective
morality I think Wes you don't you don't
give yourself enough credit you don't
you're hear you listen to these
arguments you parse them rationally you
say in some cases I guess in this speech
tonight you actually agree with his
arguments but I but I came in
disagreeing and my first principles are
a little different so I'm going to have
to consider that and but I don't know I
don't want to like I don't want to say
that someone's wrong or because you're
very nice Wes my
only advice as an older man coming you
know I was a student once much less
open-minded than you I would say you can
be less nice you got you can give
yourself permission to be right about
the things that you instinctively want
to be right about that you kind of know
that you're right about you don't need
the permission of Charles Darwin or you
know 50 million Frenchmen or anything
like that your your your gut ironically
is is pretty good and it's okay to when
you hear a logical argument you can
accept the conclusion even if uh even if
all the other people tell you wrong my
just my humble advice in no way
condescending as someone who was a
student once W thank you so much thank
you Wes may not have been completely
convinced by My Views but the fact that
he showed up and sat down with someone
he fundamentally disagreed with was
impressive Wes is a student and showed a
lot more courage and integrity than many
former teachers on the AF tour that I
have encountered all of whom showed up
with all that shallow confidence in the
world screaming at my producer and
storming out of the event but who when
given the same offer to sit down with me
went mom and slunk away I'm hoping to
find more people like W who are willing
to cross the picket line to hear what
conservatives have to say and maybe even
muster the courage to talk about these
topics face to
face